Hoy es un día especial en safate el
jamar
a 300 kilómetros al sur del Cairo y
hacer por fin tendrá acceso a la red de
agua potable como agricultor y padre de
cinco hijos ya no tendrá que preocuparse
por los riesgos del agua no potable
viene debajo de la tierra es agua
subterránea es insoluble y no es
saludable tiene arena es mala para los
niños y las personas
había estado consumiendo agua sin tratar
proveniente de esta bomba ilegal la
unicef el fondo de las Naciones Unidas
para la infancia le concedió un préstamo
de 130 dólares que tendrá que devolver
en dos años Ahora podrá beber agua
potable legalmente
las multas pueden ser de hasta 5000 o
6.000 libras egipcias de 250 a 300 euros
pero no puedo permitirme pagar ni
siquiera 4000 libras soy un hombre pobre
las aguas del Nilo símbolo de
prosperidad en Egipto desde la
antigüedad son ahora insuficientes para
satisfacer las necesidades de una
población en constante crecimiento más
aún desde que Etiopía construyó aguas
arriba la gigantesca presa del
renacimiento que le permite regular el
caudal del río desde este año el 98% de
los 109 millones de habitantes del país
como yacer dependen directamente de este
río 500 kilómetros más al norte se
encuentran las fértiles tierras del
delta del Nilo el granero de Egipto aquí
el agua de los afluentes del Nilo
siempre se ha utilizado para regar los
campos
como pueden verlo el agua viene de aquí
se va por allá
Mohamed del said cultiva arroz y tiene
que inundar sus tierras Aunque la
agricultura representa el 80% del
consumo de agua potable en Egipto el
gobierno impuesto controles más
estrictos sobre el uso de los recursos
tenemos tres o cuatro días de agua y dos
o tres días secos
en los tres días de agua el campo está
completamente inundado
los días secos hay un poco de agua para
los que quieran usar un poco más el agua
Sigue estando disponible no hay ningún
problema
este sistema de rotación no le conviene
a todos por igual más al norte en
tierras menos ricas la familia de Zoe
lleva generaciones cultivando yute que
también requiere mucha agua pero su
turno por el agua llega después que el
del resto
Yo quiero irrigar el quiero irrigar este
otro quiere irrigar todo el mundo quiere
irrigar vale Pero cómo lo hacemos
intentamos trabajar uno tras otro
pero a veces se le da prioridad al arroz
que es un cultivo prioritario para el
Estado
el yute también es un cultivo
prioritario
pero los rendimientos no son los mismos
[Música]
desde hace más de 10 años con la subida
del nivel del mar Mediterráneo la
salinización ha degradado las tierras de
Zoey quien se siente desanimado
pero si no queda nada a dónde voy a ir
voy a tener que dejarlo todo e irme
se acabó tendré que probar suerte en
otra parte
para ayudar a los agricultores el
gobierno egipcio realizó una gran
inversión en el tratamiento del agua con
la ayuda de fondos internacionales
la planta gabala suar es la más grande
de su clase en África y Oriente medio
cada día trata las aguas residuales de
12 millones de personas más de la mitad
de la población del Cairo
utilizamos esta agua para la agricultura
en lugar de utilizar mucha agua potable
a los agricultores les proporcionamos
agua tratada
actualmente producimos 2.5 millones de
metros cúbicos al día y esperamos llegar
a los 3.5 millones en 2027
en un país en el que crecen las
desigualdades sociales los balnearios
privados para las clases medias altas se
han multiplicado a lo largo del
Mediterráneo toda la costa al oeste de
Alejandría se ha llenado de concreto
pero el Nilo no llega hasta aquí Así que
la gente debe aprovechar las aguas
subterráneas que se filtran desde el mar
este empresario ha instalado una
veintena de pequeñas unidades de
desalinización en estos pueblos
vacacionales de la costa
este sistema abastece de agua potable a
700 hogares
es muy práctico porque es una planta
instalada en un contenedor que se puede
desplazar
solo se conecta y se obtiene agua
en este caso perforamos pozos y Los
Pozos son adaptados a esta escala no
podemos asegurar que resuelva los
problemas pero es parte de la solución a
esos problemas a medida que Egipto ve
que sus recursos se agotan tendrá que
asumir el reto de su gestión del agua
sobre todo porque su población podría
alcanzar